patience is a virtue  i suppose it probably is but i think  patience real patience is an expression  of deep understanding you see  everything happens when it's supposed to  happen everything in this universe  happens by  law we set targets and we need things to  happen we need something to come or  someone to do something  and frequently we get frustrated because  it isn't happening when we think it  should happen  our problem is we're not thinking we  believe we're in charge we are not in  charge  we are in charge of building the idea  and holding the idea everything else  happens automatic it happens by law  all ideas have a gestation or an  incubation period  i'm told when we plant a carrot in the  area of the world that i live  it takes approximately 70 days for that  carrot to grow